[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
رضا الناس غايه لا تدرك ورضى الله غايه لا
تترك فاترك ما لا يدرك وادرك ما لا يترك
السلام
[موسيقى]
ان ذلك من عزم الامور ان ذلك
لمن عزم الامور ما الفرق بينهما
يقول تعالى في سوره لقمان يا بني اقم
الصلاه وامر بالمعروف وانهى عن المنكر
واصبر على ما اصابك ان ذلك من عزم الامور
كان السياق القراني وصيه من جمله وصايا لم
يحتمل الغريما ولا ندا فجاء السياق من
عزمي بلا تاكيد بينما قال تعالى في سوره
الشورى ولمن صبر وغفر ان ذلك لمن عزم
الامور فكانت الايه تتحدث عن اذى غريم وعن
عظم الصبر عليه والعفو عنه لذا اكد الكلام
باللام لمن عزم الامور دلاله على الفضل
المترتب عليه
[موسيقى]
لليل عند العرب قصص لذا قسموه اسداسا
الاصيل هو الوقت من اقصى العصر الى المغرب
والاحمرار وقت الغروب ثم الغسق وهو ظلمه
الليل
وياتيك الدجى وهو سواد الليل وظلمته وجوف
الليل هو ثلثه الاخير والسحر هو اخر الليل
قبيل الفجر
[موسيقى]
اسره الانسان هي افراد عائلته وربما نجد
في معاني الكلمه في المعجم ما يفيد بمصدر
اللفظ يقال الاسر الشد والعصب وشده والخلق
والخلق يقول تعالى نحن خلقناهم وشددنا
اسرهم اي شددنا خلقهم والاسره الدرع
الحصين
[موسيقى]
وفي متعه المرور في بال الحبيب قال الوئاء
الدمشقي
لكرامه اعرض طلالي هواني لم تجفني حتى
اهتممت بشاني اصل التغضب في هواك محبه تدع
المحب بصوره الغضبان فشغل فؤادك بي فلست
موداليا
اشغلته بهوايا ام هجراني
وقال ابن الدبينه
تعاللت كي اشجع وما بك عله تريدين قتلي قد
ظفرت بذلك
وقولك للعواد كيف تونه فقالوا قتيلا قلت
اهونها
ان يلتني بمساءه لقد سرني اني خطرت ببالك
مساك اهل العشق ما كنت اشتري جميع حياتي
العاشقين بدرهمي
يقول الله تعالى فاعتبروا يا اولي الابصار
اي خذوا العبره واتعظوا وهذا معنى الفعل
اعتبر لذا قل اعد الامر صعبا او سهلا ولا
تقل اعتبره
وارحم لسانك من تاثير الترجمات فلا تقل
قامت الحكومه بانشاء مستشفى بل قل انشات
الحكومه مستشفى ولا تقل تم تنظيم ندوه عن
كذا بل قل نظمت ندوه وهكذا فهو ارطب على
اللسان واحسن في الذاكره
ابتعد عن فاتح وغامق في وصفك للالوان عد
الى سعه العربيه ورحابتها وقل
القطن ابيض ناصع والزهر اصفر فاقع والدم
احمر قانا وقانا والليل اسود حالك والزرع
اخضر ناظر والافق ازرق زاهد
[موسيقى]
حين ياتيك احدهم بخبر سعيد او يسهل لك
مصلحه يقال لك اعطيه الحلوان والحلوان
جاءت في القواميس بمعنى المشابه يورد
القاموس المحيط انها اجره الدلال
والكاهن ومهر المراه او
متعتها او ما اعطي كرشوه
اذا طلبت من احدهم زياده في امر تقول له
بحبحها وفي اللسان
البحبحي الواسع في النفقه الواسع في
المنزل
وتبحبح في المجد اي انه في مجد واسع وفي
الجذر ذاته تقول بح اذا نفد الشيء وانتهى
وهي اختصار لبحباح وفي القاموس المحيط
بحباح كلمه تنبئ عن نفاذ الشيء وثناء
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل اذكرتني الطعن وكنت ناسيا فما
قصه هذا المثل
هذا مثل يقال لمن نسي امرا هاما يفيده
وقيل له ما يذكره به وقصه المثل ان رهم بن
حزن الهلالي انتقل باهله وماله من بلده
يريد بلدا اخر
فاعترضه قوم من تغلب فعرفوه وهو لم يعرفهم
فقالوا له خلي ما معك وانجوا فقال لهم
دونكم المال ولا تعرضوا للحرم يقصد النساء
فقال له بعضهم ان اردت ان نفعل ذلك فالقي
رمحك فنظر الى يمينه واذا فيها رمح وقال
ان معي لرمحا فشد عليهم فجعل يقتل واحدا
واحدا وهو ينشد ردوا على اقربها الاقاصيا
ان لها بالمشرفي حاديا ذكرتني الطعنه وكنت
ناسياه
ذكرتني الطعنه وكنت ناسيا
[موسيقى]
الكفاله تكون بالنفس بينما الضمانه بالمال
فانت تكفل اجيرا عند رب العمل او صديقا
عند اخر بينما تضمن الارض او العقار اي
تفتديهما بالمال وقت الحاجه
اكثر الادواء والاوجاع في كلام العرب جاءت
على فعال كالصداع والسعال والزكام والبحاح
والدوار والهلاس وهو مرض السل والكباب
والصفار والكزاز والفواق والخناق ابعدها
الله عنكم جميعا
يقول المتنبي اذا استشفيت من داء بداء
فاقتل ما اعلك ما شفاك
[موسيقى]
امر والي المدينه الجديد باصحاب الملاهي
فحبسوا وحبس معهم ابو هارون اعترض المغني
الفقيه
فاخبروه اخبروا الوالي ان اطرد هذا من اهل
الهيئه والمروءه والنعمه والدين
فدعى به وخلى سبيله وامر برفع حوائجه اليه
وبينما اعترض خارج من عند الوالي بعد شكره
والدعاء له فاذا هو بالمغنين احضروا
ليعرضوا فعندما راهم عاد الى الوالي وقال
اصلح الله الامير على الغناء حبست هؤلاء
قال نعم قال فلا تظلمهم ايها الامير
فوالله ما احسن منه شيئا وهم ليسوا بمغنين
فضحك الوالي كثيرا وخلى سبيلهم
[موسيقى]
قال لنا الجاحظ ومن عاقب على الصغير
بعقوبه الكبير على الهفوه بعقوبه الاسرار
وعلى الخطا بعقوبه العمد وعلى معصيه
المتستر بعقوبه معصيه المعلن ومن لم يفرق
بين الاعالي والاسافل وبين الاقاصي
والاداني عقب على الزنا بعقوبه السرق وعلى
القتل بعقوبه القذف ومن خرج الى ذلك في
باب العقاب خرج الى مثله في باب الثواب
ومن خرج من جميع الاوزان وخالف جميع
التعديل كان بغايه العقاب احق وبه اولاه
ووضع الندى في موضع السيف بالعلى مضرا
كوضع السيف في موضع الندى
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر ما هو الكتاب الذي
قراتموه اربع مرات في ذلك اشاره الى اهميه
الكتاب عندكم وقد وصلتني منكم مشاركات
كثيره استعرض بعضا منها
هذه مشاركه من رامي يقول التنميه الاسئله
الكبرى للراحل السعودي الدكتور غازي
القصيبي رحمه الله عليه
من مؤلفات الدكتور غازي ايضا كتاب قراته
اربع مرات انا هو كتاب
حياه في الاداره كتاب يستحق ان يقرا عشر
مرات ايضا
اناث تقول يقول العقاد رحمه الله ان تقرا
كتابا جيدا ثلاث مرات افضل من قراءه ثلاثه
كتب جديده تقول وها انا ذا اعيد قراءه
العقد وهي تقصد العقد الفريد
دكتور سعد يقول كتاب لانك الله للمؤلف علي
جابر الفيفي
وعبد العزيز عبد الله غراب يقول كتاب
الفتن والملاحم لابن كثير
وشارك ايضا من معتز الخطيب يقول كتاب
حياتي ولا نعرف هل يقصد حياته هو ام يقصد
كتاب حياتي لاحمد امين الله اعلم زينه
تقول دع القلق وابدا الحياه قراته اكثر من
مره
واحمد الجاري يقول رساله الغفران لابي
العلاء المعري
ومشاركه ايضا من احمد امين يقول النظرات
للمنفلوطي
وخزامى الشنيور تقول تاريخ الفلسفه في
الاسلام تقول بعد الامتحانات اتم الرابعه
بالتوفيق ان شاء الله
ومشاركه من
السرقسطي يقول مقدمه ابن خلدون والعقد
الفريد ولا ابالغ ان قلت انها اكثر من
اربع مرات
نتابع معكم في هذه المشاركات الجميله
مشاركه من محمد صديق يقول مذكرات قارئ
لعلي حامد الاحمري هو ليس عليا هو محمد
حامد الاحمري يقول وكان بتوصيه منك في
تاملات يسعدني ذلك والله يا محمد
وتابع معكم في هذه المشاركات وهذه
المشاركه من محمود عثمان يقول لعبه الامم
لمايلز كوبلن هو مايلز كوبلاند يا محمود
وهو عميل سابق في وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه هذا الكتاب الذي اثار
زلزالا في الاوساط السياسيه والدبلوماسيه
ومشاركه اخيره من ادم يقول روايه القوقعه
هذه الروايه ايها الساده فيها
كميه هائله من الالم
والوجع الحقيقه انني قراتها قبل سنوات
طويله ولا اعتقد انني استطيع ان اقراها
مره ثانيه بعض
الالم نصل من الهشاشه بمكان ان لا نستطيع
ان نعود اليه مره اخرى
طبعا
الكاتب هو
مخرج سينمائي سوري اسمه مصطفى خليفه هذا
الرجل يعني قضى في السجون سنوات طويله
اتوقع اكثر من عشرين سنه او اقل او اكثر
من عشرين سنه
بتهمه انه من الاخوان المسلمين علما انه
مسيحي نصراني
وكان خاله وزيرا
في الحكومه ولم يستطع ان يفعل له شيئا
اذا كنت من محبي الوجع الشديد فاقراها
والا فلا على كل حال اشكر لكم هذه
المشاركات واذكركم دائما بان تضعوا وسم
تاملات الجزيره عند نهايه كل مشاركه
[موسيقى]
الشاعر العربي يريد المراه حيه خجولا
ولا ندري عن شعراء الحداثه فقد يكسرون
القالب ويصوغون نموذجا مختلفا وكما ان
هناك شعراء حداثه فهناك شوارع وحداثه بعض
الناس يزعمون ان الخجل سمه طبيعيه في
المراه متغلله في الجينات وبعضهم يفسر
الامر بانه نتيجه مجتمعيه
الشاعر السوري عمر ابو ريشه ليس من اهل
الحداثه ولا ما بعد الحداثه لكنه من اهل
ما قبل الخجل بالنسبه للفتاه هو يصورها
بريئه الى درجه انها لا تعرف كيف تخجل
الفيتها ساهمه
شارده تاملا ناديتها فالتفت جيدا وشعرا
مرسلا فمن سنت حائره ولا رنت تدللا ولا
درت وجنتها من خجل تبدلا كانها في طهرها
اطهر من ان تخجل
لكن شاعرنا يتذوق الجمال والفتنه بطريقه
اخرى لقد راى فتنه في الحجر واشبعها وصفا
كان عمر ابو ريشه سفيرا لسوريا في عده
بلاد في اقصى الغرب واقصى الشرق فبعد ان
تحقق الاستقلال كان في اواسط الثلاثين من
العمر وكان له نشاط سياسي في زمن
الاستعمار الفرنسي ضمن الكتله الوطنيه
واحيانا منشقا عنها لكن ضمن الاطار الوطني
المناهض للاستعمار فكان طبيعيا ان يكون
مرشحا لمنصب سياسي لكن اهل الحل والعقد
اثروا ان يكون بعيدا عن الشام هو ولسانه
وما جعله الخيار المناسب انه يجيد
الانجليزيه لقد درس في بريطانيا في مطلع
شبابه
في الهند كانت الروايه الحجريه زار معبدا
تجلد جدرانه التماثيل الرخامي يقول
[موسيقى]
كم دميه ذل الرخام على انتفاضتها وهان
فكان هذه الدمى الحسان انتفضت وخرجت من
الرخام بشرا سويا يقول
يرقصن في اغرائهن وكل قد افعوان
وصبيه ممشوقه هي والغوايه توامان
وتكاد تنقل ظلها وتسهير مطلقه العنان
هذان نضوى صبوه مجنونه
يتعانقان ذمه شفاههما على معسول ما
تتساقيان
كان عمر ابو ريشه من شباب الكتله الوطنيه
التي يتزعمها ابن مدينته حلب سعد الله
الجابري كان ضمن الشباب الوطني ذراع
الشبابيه للكتله الوطنيه
وانشق الشباب الوطني بعد توقيع الكتله على
معاهده مع الفرنسيين
واطلق ابو ريشه لسانه في الجابري منتقدا
وبعد انسحاب اخر جندي فرنسي من سوريا كان
الجابري رئيسا للوزراء ولم تمضي سنه على
الاستقلال حتى
توفي الجابري فرثاه عمر ابو ريشه مذكرا
بالخلاف القديم
حمل الجرح صامتا مطمئنا واتى ربه على
ميعادى انا يا سعد ما طويت على اللؤم
جناحي ولا جرحت اعتقادي شهد الله من تقدك
الا طمعا ان اراك فوق انتقادي وكفى المراه
رفعه ان يعادى في ميادين مجده ويعادي
كان اعتذارا انيقا وشامخا للراحل جاء في
ثوب الرثاء
[موسيقى]
سلام على القدس ما هو القلوب سلام يطاول
عالي الثمر تقود الى النصر كل الدروب تسير
الى خالد وعمر السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]